in your right angle triangle we now want
to transition from thinking just about
sides and how they relate to each other
and also considering how they're related
to
the angles inside your triangle okay so
for instance i'm going to call this
angle here in the corner hmm
let's be fancy because you guys are g1
i'm gonna call it theta
okay so that's um i'll draw it for you
again it's a it's a zero with a tail in
the middle like that okay um they tend
to use greek letters for um
for angles i don't know why this greek's
cool anyway so i'm going to call that
angle theta over there
now so far we've been calling these a b
and c c has been the important one okay
i want to shift your perspective on this
a little bit
and think about how would i describe or
label each of these sides in relation to
this angle that's important over here
okay
now the hypotenuse we've already got a
special name for that so we'll just
leave that b
okay the hypotenuse always the
hypotenuse okay
but now the other two sides i want to
distinguish between them okay
particularly in relation to the angle
okay so this is sort of my perspective
i'm standing here and thinking about
well how would i describe these two
differently right well this guy up here
on the left right um it's facing the
angle it's directly
opposite isn't it right so i'm going to
call this side over here the opposite
side
it's opposite theta
okay
now what word could we use to describe
this one that's down the bottom here
it's next to theta so i'm going to call
it adjacent because
the next two angle is true but doesn't
sound pretty articulate so they go okay
now obviously if i change the angle if i
change my point of reference if i went
up here
what would change
they'd swap around wouldn't they
hypotenuse is still where it is okay but
for this angle this is opposite and this
is adjacent okay
so this is nine gene this is exercise 9h
all you have to do
is work out which one's which okay so
you're like
really
we're seeing your students now come on
okay
and admittedly
it's just a warm-up
it's just a warm-up for this next thing
i actually want you to make space for
self-hating but just leave it off for a
second okay and we'll see if you can
work out how long it'll take you for you
to work out what this thing is actually
called okay
underneath your blank sub heading i want
you to draw two right angle triangles
for me but this time
i want you to draw them similar to each
other so for instance
you might draw one that's um
three
four five you don't actually have to
label them but maybe you want to get a
ruler out so you can actually have some
measurements here okay
your next one over maybe we can make it
6
8
10.
okay so this is two similar triangles
and we're going to talk about what's
going on between the sides and the
angles here
okay for you to catch up a second
let's give these triangles some names i
going to call this one p
q
r and we'll call this one
x y
z and you can see i've got a theta there
in the corner okay
now i think most of you are starting to
catch up
let's try just a few things about this
okay
triangle pqr triangle p q
r
is similar to triangle xyz what's our
symbol for similarity
it's three lines which way they go they
go horizontal or do they go vertical
they go vertical
the way i remember it uh is that if you
got these across that's telling you
everything everything is equal about
this right okay we call this the
equivalence relationship but clearly not
everything is equal here right this
guy's bigger yeah so
it's close but it's not every single
thing so that's how i remember that
that's what's that it's not similarity
it's
it's congruence when you talk about
triangles right so it's not that okay on
the ball today um it's similarity so
triangle pqr is similar to triangle we
call it x y z
okay
now therefore we can say that
and i've actually already labeled it on
there right
angle p r q
is equal to
angle
x z and y what would be the reason that
you give for that
i could actually say a reason everything
starts with a big long awkward word
starting with a c and remember it
corresponding
corresponding now i'm talking about
angles aren't i right corresponding
angles
in
similar
triangles goodness this is long
r
equal right
good okay so and i've already put that
in there i'm just calling both of them
theta okay
now
have a look at these sides i can make a
statement about the sides of these
triangles and how they relate just like
i can make a statement about the angles
and how they relate right
so for instance let's have a look at
this one
p q
okay now think back when we're doing
this right
in this little triangle over here the
small one
p q which side is it in relation to the
angle
it's the opposite side isn't it and you
can see it's sort of you know
it's looking all the way to the other
side of the triangle so it's opposite
okay
so pq
if i divide that i take the ratio of pq
over
pr which is the hypotenuse okay
that ratio should be the same as another
ratio in the other triangle which sides
is it x y
good x y which again is the opposite
side
over x z which again is the hypotenuse
okay
now we gave a reason for this statement
what reason do we give for this one
it's close but it's not five percent
still starts with corresponding
corresponding obviously it's not angles
it's sides okay it's still in similar
triangles
okay
so we've got a choice here the first way
you could say is they're in the same
ratio
are in the same
ratio because what you've got here
here's a ratio right and here's another
one and they're the same
three over five sure is equal to six
over ten right
uh another way you can say it in case
you don't like writing three words here
is you can say in proportion
both of them accepted in the hsc they're
both equivalent okay
okay now remember we're making this big
deal about an opposite and hypotenuse
and all that kind of thing right
so what you really got here
is that opposite side over the
hypotenuse i'm just going to remove it
because all these words are long okay
the opposite side in the hypotenuse
in one triangle
right is equal to
the opposite side on the hypotenuse
in the other one
right
now i could draw another triangle
couldn't i could draw a third one and a
fourth and a fifth
and a 500th okay and if they're all
similar
then all of these ratios are always
going to be the same can we agree to
that is that okay
so therefore
like you know what what might the
triangles be it might be something like
oh i don't know 300
400
500 okay
the side lengths aren't what matters
okay the sideways can change wherever
you can make this triangle as big or as
small as you like what's the thing which
really stays the same
what's the common feature between all
these triangles that makes them similar
it's not science
what is it
now scales are good isn't it i guess if
you said scale we're relation to each
other that'd be okay but actually the
scale is really changing you're getting
small things and then going into big
things right
i'll tell you what's the same
that angle is still going to be the same
right every single time no matter how
enormous you make your triangle okay
that angle in the corner there is always
going to be the same for this reason
that we've set up here
right
so what really matters is not the side
lengths it's the angle okay it's so
important
the angle right
that we give these ratios
names when you're talking about ratios
and angles and how they go together for
instance this one opposite hypotenuse
doesn't remember what it's called
this is hard to remember this this one
is sine this one is sine you're like why
did i start with sine i'll tell you in a
second why
this one we would call sine theta well
it's always the same angle isn't it okay
sine theta in all of these triangles is
always equal to three over five so long
as theta stays whatever it is i don't
know it looks like
about 42 degrees or something like that
okay
no matter what triangle you're in it's
always equal to this ratio so long as
the angle is the same okay
now that's opposite on hypotenuse
opposite on
hypotenuse the other ratios are also
important and there are three sides so
you have three ratios three ways to pair
them up
opposite not hypotenuse i can do the
adjacent side that's this one right
the adjacent side over the hypotenuse
okay does anyone remember what that
one's called so let's see it's cars well
it's short for cosine but we
we're always looking for a shorter way
to write it okay so in these triangles
it'll be
adjacent over hypotenuse four and five
right in this triangle that we've got
okay
and there's one more that we look at one
more combination of these which is the
opposite side over the adjacent side so
forgetting about the hypotenuse for a
second
and we call this one tan which is short
for tangent okay
um what is it in this case
it's opposite
over adjacent so it's three quarters
okay
um you may notice as well three-quarters
that's the same as saying
sine
on cos can you see that
this over this gives you three over four
the fives cancel out okay
so
i admit it is pretty hard to remember
and you're like why are we introducing
all this new language anyway so there's
a mnemonic if you've learned it if
you've heard of it before
called sakatoa
hands up if that's to femininity yes
good okay
so sine goes with opposite eye
hypotenuse right cosine goes with
adjacent or hypotenuse
tan goes with opposite line adjacent and
there you go okay by the way what should
we call this subheading
i could call a software but that's kind
of a tool to help you what is this
really about
these are called the trigonometric
ratios now just think about that for a
second obviously they're ratios because
that's what we've been talking about the
whole time right is comparing two sides
how big one is versus the other
we call trigonometric ratios well we
know what metric means right metric just
means about measurement that's why we
call our measurement system the metric
system
what's this thing
what's a trigon
we don't tend to think we don't talk
about trigons very much we're usually
more familiar with their
more common friends polygons right
many angles
three angles so these are the ratios to
do with measuring sorry measuring
triangles crazy backwards
but anyway there you go okay so that's
the heading you can pull over all of
this